controversy has been erupting over the
past couple of months pertaining to the
olympics
we had this alternate for the olympic
bmx park i think it is
saying that their intention was to get
on the podium to burn the american flag
and then that got everybody
i think mostly everybody listens to fox
news riled up because most of the
left-wing guys didn't really talk about
it
and now we have the stories actually
picking up steam and has become pretty
viral
of this woman who won third place in the
hammer throw
protesting the national anthem now
that's still i find it interesting that
we we have the culture war getting to
the point where people are torn between
whether to be proud of themselves the
olympics and happy that america has
chosen them and
protesting it to virtue signal well of
course joe biden's going to come out and
say hey come on man you know it's it's a
right to protest and you know
oh come on dude it's the olympics you're
going to stand up you're going to be
like
you know we're here for america and i
get it protest has happened in the
olympics but i think the culture war is
getting that point where
a lot of people actually want to be
proud of themselves but they're torn
between the virtue signal or otherwise
so
we're going to talk about that we got a
bunch of other serious stories as well
there's a right-wing watch as you may
have heard was briefly banned
and as they say live by the sword this
is an organization that lives to get
conservatives and people on the right
banned or at least
hurt them financially all in the name of
getting democrats elected
so we'll talk about that stuff too get
political and we are being joined today
by our number one fan
and number one troll of our chat adrian
curry i'm not a troll anymore i will no
longer be trolling
now you're on the show yeah no you're
actually like i just
deadpooled it i broke down the wall so
now i can't troll
yeah i still haven't seen that movie is
it good it's great
it's fantastic and i thought he would do
a horrible job and i was very wrong
i thought it was yeah i was i was i was
enthusiastic but do you want to actually
just briefly introduce yourself um
i am i am a reality tv
original i've been retired since 2015.
i am now just an avon lady but the
reason
i i like to blame the narcissism in the
world on
uh me and kelly clarkson because we won
top model
and american idol in the same year and
thus began
the slow decline of society it's all
your fault thanks
thanks for being here and you're welcome
it was right around when we
the iraq war began and that was really
uh a powerful year right
everyone's a model on instagram now and
we're still
at war in the middle east
uh hey thanks guys i'm ian crossland
adrian i'm glad you're here i've been
following your work for
eight months or so i'm sorry
but i'm invigorated yeah i'm delighted
to have adrian here because our
birthdays are very close together and
she's the same height as i am and we
have the same shoe size i freaking love
it i'm a huge fan now so
big checks we got big feet yeah good
stuff
all right i'm gonna throw back to tim
you're stunned by this best conversation
head over to eatrightandfeelwell.com
to check out biotrust's keto elevate
c8mct
oil powder it sounds complicated but
it's actually just kind of like this
powdered fat you put in your drinks your
smoothies and it gives you clean burning
energy ian's always ragging on the sugar
industry
it's so good oh you just put them in
this guy i did i did i just wanted to
say it but
all you got to do is listen to the show
and you know how much ian is saying the
sugar is bad and the sugar industry was
manipulating everybody this is the
healthy stuff
this is the good stuff mct oil powder
see it from keto elevate
and if you're trying to lose weight or
just eat better
or take better you know but better care
of yourself in terms of
you don't want to eat the nasty sugars
the carbs the starches the garbage food
i'm trying to eat a lot better so go
again eatrightandfeelwell.com this stuff
is fantastic
medium chain triglyceride is the good
stuff it gives you sustained energy
levels it's fantastic and we got some
things you got to know
biotrust has a 60-day money ba
money-back guarantee guarantee
can't speak keto elevate provides your
body only c8 the most
ketogenic mct in its purest form that
means it provides very fast and
effective support
for enhanced energy levels healthy
appetite management enhanced mental
clarity and focus
athletic performance keto elevate is
very gentle on your stomach
five grams of the highly sought after
mct8
purse per scoop keto elevate is the most
advanced mct powder on the market today
and they give you free shipping on every
order
and that's eatrightandfeelwell.com for
every order today
biotrust donates a nutritious meal to a
hungry child in your honor
through their partnership with no kid
hungry.org to date biotrust has provided
over 4.4
million meals to hungry kids please help
biotrust hit their goal of 5 million
meals this year
and they give you free vip free vip live
health and fitness coaching
from their team of expert nutrition and
health coaches for
life with every order that that to me is
always the craziest thing i've ever read
that i'm like
that's a ridiculous deal man free new
e-report the top 14 ketogenic foods with
every order definitely check it out
eatrightandfeelwell.com and this is
something that michael mal's brought up
i always got to shout this out because
he made a really important point when he
was here last and we did an ad read
he was like guys these are the companies
that are helping support
our speech the ideas we have and this
this like you know cultural battle
defending individual individuality so
these companies are the ones that you
need to be supporting
these aren't the companies that want to
cancel you they're the ones who are
outright like hey we got a cool thing
and we like what you're doing so again
eatrightandfeelwell.com check it out 51
off
don't forget go to timcast.com become a
member to get access
access to our exclusive members only
segments and help support our newsroom
we just hired three people oh this is
crazy
every day i i look at how many people we
have working here and it's more and more
and i'm like i'm like
every every person we hire is me putting
shackles on where i have to make sure
the company runs
i have to be responsible for doing more
but it is because so many of you signed
up and so
quickly i felt the responsibility to do
my best to make sure we can bring all
these people on so we literally just
hired three people
for production so we can do a lot more
we got another person who's coming in
tomorrow
to join the newsroom we're gonna be
hiring another person an editor then a
building manager and a receptionist man
what's going on we're making a company
here
that's fantastic and it's all thanks to
you so we're gonna have a a bonus
segment with adrian at the uh around 11
or so it goes up
and this is all the the dirty secrets
and stuff that we're not allowed to talk
about on youtube so you're gonna want to
stick around for this
but for now we'll be talking about the
important
news of the day we got this we got this
really interesting story
it's this one strikes me as an odd story
all right so here's this
here it is from daily mail biden quote
respects olympic hammer thrower gwen
berry's
right to turn back on flag and believes
being patriotic means to recognize when
u.s hasn't lived up
to its highest ideal this is the big
story right now
she won third place which means she's
found she's secured a spot on the
olympic team
going to tokyo but when they played the
national anthem
the two other women who got first and
second place turn and put their hands on
their on their on their hearts
and she turns and makes makes this like
angry look and then says stop playing
with me
then says i was being set up it's they
did it on purpose they were going to
play it before but they knew they got me
and it's like
you're it's america like we live in
america you know you're going to the
olympics
to support the country turning away from
your own anthem or being mad that the
anthem's being played to me is like kind
of
weird but here's here's here's the core
of what i want to get into in terms of
this discussion
the culture war has got to the point
where i kind of feel like this lady
and her mom and her family were probably
crying with joy that she
she's in the olympics she won and she
did it but when they play the national
anthem she's she's being torn right
if she stands there and puts her hands
on her heart her hand on her heart for
the national anthem how many of these
like black lives matter activists
leftists are going to be like
why would you do that why would you
support the oppression
and so i wonder if her attitude was kind
of like what do i do
maybe it's like the movie cuties like
the family was so
proud of their children for doing this
movie
and everyone else is like what but
they're just gonna stand by it anyway
because
that's their girl you know so maybe it's
just that kind of like tribalism like
you're familiar you're just gonna stand
up for these people
even though i mean the fact that our our
president
like oh please help me help
can i go back to montana now like no you
got this why would he be okay with this
why would any president be like yes
hate our country it's great they're
there there have been people who did
like the the the
you know the power fists the black power
fists or aka red salute in the past
so i recognized protests at the olympics
they banned was that like going like
to the flag no no right that was not
pooping on the flag that was like oh i'm
gonna do a protest but not
blatantly be like i hate this country
that i represent
and i lost very badly but let's uh
differentiate between doing cuties and
making the olympics
those little girls and cuties were being
abused no no no no
i think doing what she did to the flag
was abused so i'm really
the olympics awesome like these people
are great
i think she was just so mad that she
didn't win that the only way to take the
moment from the winner was to make it
all about herself i thought it was
incredibly narcissistic
yeah because like the person who was in
first place now it's not don't even
knows her name nobody knows and nobody
cares it's like going to a wedding and
making it all about you and stealing the
bride's thunder how much you want to bet
she gets a deal with nike and they do
something stand up even if everyone says
you're wrong help us oppress
more people being out of depression
yeah well not subpar obviously she's
greater
she's par she's part she's thirsty
athlete yeah what if she actually
focused on being a better athlete
instead of hating her country
and activism maybe she would have been
first i never got the
not burning destroying the flag thing
like i was always like
yeah destroy the flag cool whatever i'm
not into like iconic
was it iconic iconoclast is that with
iconic classic i'm not into like
idol worship like i worshipping icons so
i don't
know why people care that it's a
piece of cloth like maybe 200 years ago
when you needed it to say this is my
army
there was a purpose for the it but
nowadays it seems like that's where i go
full-blown republican
where i'm like why don't you go burn the
hollywood sign because that has hurt
so many people but america has like
given us so much great stuff
like why i think i figured it out
actually because i was thinking about
this story
and i remember this thing that penn and
teller did
where they burned the american flag as a
magic trick they don't really burn it
but they like
roll the constitution and then he puts
the flag in it and then a flame comes
out and the flag's gone
and he's and uh penn says he's a very
libertarian guy burning the flag is the
ultimate symbol of the freedom that it
represents
so i've always been a fan of that idea
so long as it's your flag and you're
safe i don't care but
but i think i figured it out i'm like
why does this one upset me
like why why should i complain about a
lady who's expressing the freedom of
america by protesting
and it's simple like sure when i'm at
home and i'm fighting with my parents i
can say really nasty things about my
siblings
it doesn't leave the house but we
express that internally and we go
outside
someone says nasty things about my
family i'll be like don't you talk about
my family that way
yeah she's representing our country
exactly
and she's like you all suck and i'm like
you suck you
lost technically she
she lost i guess you could say
technically no not this participation
trophy nobody is happy with their silver
and bronze
nobody's happy no i used to run track
and cross country i was
never happy oh here's your third place i
was like
are you happy when you like rank bad
when you're playing world of warcraft or
you didn't get a good armor drop
no like you're not proud remember
michaela maroney
she got silver and she does the face and
it became a meme because it was like
because it's true yeah she did well but
she didn't get what she wanted
one value to this uh so this this is a
person finished third place and they
burned a flag is that right or no no no
they played the national anthem
and then when the first and second place
lady turned to the flag and put their
hands on their heart
she turns to the camera and she like
makes a frumpy look like angry what it
might do that's good is show other
citizens from around the world in like
totalitarian regimes that they can also
talk crap against their government and
like kind of see the
the flames of of like no they're gonna
use it as propaganda of why we suck and
why the ccp is so great that is that's
true
that's what they do you know why because
their athletes wouldn't do that because
they
ship them off to a camp i mean it is it
is cool that we can protest in this
country but
this is like what are you protesting at
the olympics
right you you you have chosen to be
in the upper echelon of athletes of the
world
by choice you went here and did this you
knew you were going to be
wearing the american flag and they would
play the anthem when you like walk out
and your act that's why i think it's not
real
i think she's imagine it this way you
want to be
a famous and rich athlete you got to get
the endorsement that's where it's all at
it's press none of it's real none of
what anyone does for attention in front
of cameras is
real it's all a lie they only want
clicks and likes and traction
and money and because she stuck it to
the cons
how many leftist liberal types are going
like woo yeah you tell them
she'll get she'll get you know dan
crenshaw said that she should be kicked
off the team or whatever
that she i'm sure she'd love it look at
colin kaepernick he's making more money
having left the nfl
than he was at least that's my
understanding like he got this big nike
deal
wow so oppressed you know i pray for him
every night because what a rough life
he's had it hard i can't imagine you
know because
you know uh uh he just has to wake up
and then he takes a couple hundred
bills and wipes his tears away wraps
himself and slave made garments from
little children being whipped and not
paid and then he cries
about how hard his life is that's what i
always loved about the activism it's
like
they use all of this technology all of
the raw materials
from slave labor around the world mostly
in china and other you know
southeast asian countries and like
they're wearing clothes from bangladesh
and stuff and they're like i'm so
oppressed
well hasn't nike literally said nike is
a company
like of china for china yeah well then
go to china baby your market here is
dead
nike means victory i think in ancient
greek or something it doesn't
yeah oh what is it i thought it meant
pain and suffering
i mean yeah pretty much um i can see
like the value of winning
and then wrapping yourself in the
american flag and being like look this
country gave me the opportunity to
become
the great as great as i people would
complain about that too because you're
not supposed to wrap yourself in the
flag i've done it
and all my conservative buddies were mad
and i said old glory never had a better
time than when she was wrapped around me
so giving like worship to the flag
showing the flag like holding it in
in uh reverence but then i can also see
the value of like
lighting on fire and being like look
we're americans we're allowed to do this
at home but when you're representing
your country
it's like you're family you don't fight
in front of other people you don't go to
church and sit there and brawl with each
other in the pews
no i view it like you know maybe off
maybe somebody said hey would you be
interested in having a good faith debate
to discuss our differences
and the other person says absolutely
just let me know when and then offers up
the date
and then privately says i was never
actually going to debate you i have no
respect for this and then publicly use
it to jump up drum up drama
and just make money and grift of it or
like if you ask someone to do a good
faith debate
and they agreed to and then at the last
minute subbed in this other grifter guy
anyway i'm i'm half kidding i'm half
kidding but my point is like it is kind
of like that it's like
we said to this person hey we we invite
you to
you know wear our flag and represent us
and then she like gets up there and just
you know she wasn't at the olympics this
is the olympic trials and just as
basically
like like i never i never actually cared
about you i never wanted to represent
you
she said the anthem doesn't has never
represented me so i would why would i
want to represent it it's like then what
are you here for
we asked you to represent us go home
like no beef no beef
i'm not saying you're really great at
your sport i'm really impressed it's
fantastic but if you don't want to be
here
would you mind leaving so someone who
does can be i guess since it is like the
olympics it's kind of like someone for
the cleveland browns after they win the
super bowl and they take they rip off
their browns uniform they're like i'm
not a cleveland brown
i'm a human and you're like dude the
cleveland browns just won
give some rep to the cleveland browns
tonight like why are you on the team if
you don't want to be on the team dude
right yeah like colin kaepernick really
tried hard to get back in the nfl though
so this is what this is
my point i'm trying to say is i don't
think she actually knows or cares for
the most part about any of this
i think she was standing there and the
thought probably occurred to her
if i if i stand for the anthem the left
is going to come after me and say what
are you doing
black lives matter all that stuff and so
she was between a rock and a hard place
i think about colin kaepernick who's
like i'm gonna kneel during the nfl
and so then he gets basically cut nobody
wants him and he's desperate to get back
in
years later the dude is so desperate to
get back and he can't do it
nobody wants him do you really think
they would have came after her though
would it even have been a moment
that anyone would have cared about at
all no
in her circles though what with her four
friends
several years ago she she protested
something in law sponsors over it
so it seems like she might be someone
who lives in that
you know paranoid far left twitter
reality where she's like
get off twitter girl free yourself
everyone leave twitter it's amazing i'm
happier every moment
is a joy yeah what happened twitter is
the worst thing
life has been great my husband unplugged
from all the matrix he's
i mean instagram twitter facebook
everything
and what we learned was we wasted a hell
of a lot of time
sitting on these little things looking
into her phones like i got faraday bags
like shut off the phone throw it in
there everyone's listening
yeah yeah i heard he like fights bears
now he like learned how to box grizzlies
and he like
gained 200 pounds of muscle he's always
been
huge and he walks in front of me because
um we're in a traditional relationship
i'm totally fine being the woman that
doesn't mean i'm not empowered
but that's my dude and he is not a soy
latte
and if a bear is coming he he will die
first like a rooster
he would like run into battle yes i'm
his
roosters sacrificed themselves whoa they
didn't do their girls wow
have you ever seen the videos of
roosters like battling hawks and like
crazy predators dude they go for it
they're like that's my girl
it's the ultimate compliment i didn't
say chicken chicken's the
disparaging one rooster is the opposite
roosters are brave they're
they'll they'll run at a giant predator
knowing they'll die right into bed
the embodiment of testosterone they
serve no purpose other than have sex all
day
protect my chicks that's right that's
like ancient dinosaur dna
thank god i have a monogamous rooster
there we go
we pretty much do the same thing i
didn't mean he was polygamous in the
rooster sense i was it was the noble
the noble rooster rushing into battle
willing to die for his women
yeah i want to point out you mentioned
before we went on that bears hate loud
noises
so bear spray is one thing but hitting
him with like a
an air cycle okay when you hike you
gotta like be loud
so my husband will hike and stuff and if
it's not hibernation time because we
have grizzlies all over we're just like
hey bear hey bear and then really by the
way blah blah blah and then we'll slap
and be like
because they don't like it so when they
hear you coming
but a lot of people make the mistake
they're like it's so peaceful everyone
be quiet let's just and then you come
around the corner and there's a sow in
her cubs oh boy
good luck i was just i was just riding
bikes with my girlfriend through
down the appalachian trail and it was
like getting dark and i was like this is
going to be
awesome it's dear o'clock did they all
jump in front of your bike and they were
killing themselves
no but they were they were like on the
road and like they weren't having any of
us
but so we're we we rode a few miles
we're riding back and now it's
almost pitch black and it was awesome
because you can't see
anything and then allison's chain popped
off her bike oh
and so we had to stop that's like
dressing and then i'm i'm standing there
and it's really quiet and we're like i'm
lifting the bike up and just trying to
get it on and we hear like
and i'm like there's something out there
like you can hear something
running stephen king's a mess there's so
much like a mess
i'm like hurry up i don't want to stand
here in the middle of the woods in the
middle of the night and like we jumped
it was awesome though it was so exciting
like there were probably a thousand
weird creepy noises and all like
i had no idea what it was but there was
something big like
running through around us and i'm like
something's wrong
that's cool i like in the middle of the
night i get to hear the wolf packs
howling
and it's the most beautiful sound
oh so great they actually got my
husband's buck last hunting season he
was so
mad he was on the hunt for a buck and he
heard the wolves and he's like oh wolves
and then he came up and there was its
rack and this
decimated buck and he's like oh
so had he already killed the buck no he
had his eye on it so he was out like
tracking trying to get it
and he did but a little too late do you
have like positive interactions with
wolves
um one came out we were going to bowman
uh lake which is in glacier national
park like
in the boonies and a black wolf walked
in front of the car and your brain's
like oh it's a dog
it's not a dog it was a black wolf gold
gold eyes it looked us dead in the eye
and it took a dump
right there and i'm like he's really
comfortable with us like it's very rare
for to see a wolf a lot
and i have pictures of him just pinching
a loaf right in front of me i was like
what is this guy doing it was
really magical especially since my
husband and i all we do is talk about
poop so i'm like of course they came
they came to bring us entertainment
it's basically how dogs came to be you
know the wolves eventually were like you
know what i can poop in front of that
guy
totally and the guy was like yo check
out this wolf and then when you poop
your cats
and your dogs are like what you doing in
there guys
yeah i get in on this yeah standing and
you're like what are you doing it's my
door
uh well let's let's let's let's keep
going on the the conversation we were
having about the olympics and stuff yeah
because we have this story that i want
to talk about
um we mentioned it the ceo of nike says
nike is a brand that is of
china and for china i mean that makes
sense weren't they using like
slave labor in southeast asia or
sweatshops notoriously
so uh basically there's a boycott they
say
nike ceo john donahoe defended the
company's business in china this week
saying that nike is a brand of china for
china following a consumer boycott in
the country
he made the remark during a call with
wall street analysts on the company's
fourth quarter earnings when asked about
competition from chinese companies
nike drew backlash in china in march
after it issued a statement expressing
concern over reports of forced labor
in the xinjiang region other western
companies also expressed concerns about
forced labor
of minority uyghurs in cotton production
quote nike does not source products from
xinjiang and we have confirmed with our
contract suppliers
that they are not using textiles or spun
yarn from the region
nike said in a statement at the time
they reported a strong fourth quarter
congratulations whatever blah blah blah
on their profits think about how great
their first
you know half of this was we do not
source materials from
slaves in the english trust them
completely me too
yeah if they're getting their sources
about where they're getting their stuff
multi-nationals
corporations have our best interests in
heart especially
those who deal with communists and
employing children yeah
not employing pardon me do you vote
democracy oh i totally
i love joe biden and everything my
former party represents no i did not
yeah former party right yeah
lifelong democrat uh healing healing
over here
isn't it weird though there's a lot of
people now who are even becoming
conservative having because they've lost
like the democratic party's gone so
insane that i mean it's things like this
to be completely honest
since since when were the democrats the
party of big business and
you know industrialists or whatever but
it certainly became that especially
since the 90s
lbj yeah i guess that's fair to say the
90s they
they were smart i mean they had taken
over all the art and the joke was always
you know we need the
uh art filled democrats with all their
ideas and dreams and then you need the
conservatives with
their ability to make cash to help you
know those liberals
reach their ideas and dreams and make
profit
and then i think the democrats were like
why don't we just take over everything
that they have just everything
completely and then we can push
what we want and no one can stop us i do
think there's a big shift in 2015
you know we saw we bring it up a lot
bernie sanders saying no to open borders
and now the democratic party
basically just adopted all of these
neoconservative and neoliberal policy
policies so now they're basically in
defense of these big massive
multinational corporations
yeah like i'm old i'm
38 i'll be 39. that's not what democrats
were
rage against the machine which is now
rage 4 of the machine
all of this was against everything that
the democratic party is for now and it's
mind-boggling to me i just don't
understand like
all my friends are like well how could
you vote for trump i'm like uh
2008 stock market crash i lost
everything i earned in hollywood in all
my investments
gone and then my home was worthless and
i couldn't even sell it and people were
like you know what we'll just take the
note i'm like what does that mean
they're like you just
sign the house over to them and they
pick up the payments so you don't file
bankruptcy
yeah does that happen to you yes so when
people are like but joe biden and orange
man bad i'm like joe biden
ruined my life like my life was ruined
so i was i i just couldn't understand
especially all the bernie people
i'm like bernie got robbed again and you
guys are okay with it
but let's let's be honest i understand
that joe biden ruined your life but yeah
trump but orange man bad bad tweets come
on batman
i i remember when trump look look look
okay joe biden may have been
uh uh you know well to be fair bush was
present for a while
and then you know obama gets in but
donald trump said kung flu
you know what i mean like i i would
absolutely welcome
like bill maher said a complete economic
recession
you know that results in people losing
their lives if it means no more trump
that's what bill maher said right
i i watch him sometimes because i'm not
a bigot
and i can listen to other people i agree
with half of what he says and the other
half i think he's egotistically insane
but we're both celebrity advisors once
on the marijuana policy project
so i do respect some of the work he did
for marijuana reform but my god has that
man
sometimes lost his mind but usually with
just trump but yeah no i did not vote
for trump and i
lost half the people i i did vote for
trump and i lost half the people in my
life
doing so hi guys also hi michael malus
you're the reason yeah i'm here because
of you
that's the only reason i'm here he has
too much influence over us dear writer
himself
i left my mountain abode because he was
like you should do it
so we had uh we had some guys over this
weekend uh who were rollerbladers
and we have these really funny things
where it's like they're rollerblades but
they have bike wheels instead
so it's like they go on the left of your
legs wait a minute
is this like uh the return of oz yes oh
is that what it is
i don't know i just said yes i was
thinking willy wonka i'm so
old you guys don't know what return of
oz is
the first ever trick done on these weird
things
this guy andy he named it a michael
malus grind so he actually jumped up and
did a grind and then he called it
the michael malus grind and i sent it to
michael and he was laughing like how is
this real life this is amazing
life is so fun that's an upbeat guy he's
very interesting like
the most cheerful anarchist ever he's
just
he's i mean i'm not into anarchy
completely i
i understand respect it because i'm not
a bigot but
yeah speaking speaking of bigots you
know to go back to bill maher
i think what you were saying like half
the things he says
are like nuts him and sam harris sam
harris actually tweeted something about
this i was like he was tweeting a bunch
of people i was responding to him
where it seems like what he was saying
was and i could be getting this wrong so
forgive me if i'm getting wrong but my
understanding was
that he he understands everything's
worse under joe biden
but at least now without trump the path
is clear for him to start speaking with
liberals
or something like that like well now
that trump's gone we can actually start
talking to these people and
talking them down or something and it's
like wait wait wait like everything's
worse
what's the what's the point of talking
to liberals don't understand yet that
progressives are not with you they hate
you and want you to die and your party
is gone
it's gone because i considered myself
liberal right leaning you know but
that doesn't exist anymore it is only
the far left and a whole bunch of
old boomers that don't understand yet
that their party is dead
i don't think i think this want power so
like to bill maher
like come on you see this guy complain
about cancel culture
you see him talk about the sjws he has
milo on his show he has brett weinstein
in his show
but he also and this is my assumption of
his character based on what he says
knows that if he actually said trump's
not that bad
he'd he'd be figuratively strung up ego
and money he will never admit that he's
wrong
it'll never happen a powerful man who's
been in a powerful position for a long
time
will never admit they're wrong not even
trump
yeah they don't do it so yeah he's not
going to do it
but i do appreciate when he's trying to
rattle some lefties
awake like i'll give him that like i
don't agree with everything but thank
you bill
i can't i can't say that you know look
maybe he actually just has always had
trump derangement syndrome
and i know a lot of people are probably
like who cares about trump he's he's not
in the
trump's gonna run again and they're
ramping up the tax against them already
because they know he's
regardless of whether or not he runs
maybe it's desantis he's got influence
so these attacks are popping up
you want to be punk you want to rage
against the machine
vote orange that's what i said you think
that sam harris and like others maybe
like bill maher think that with trump
out of office
it's it's a more dangerous path that we
walk now with biden as president but
it's more unified
so that there's more of a chance to i
think it's that they
genuinely didn't like trump but they
knew biden and the establishment were
really really bad
but trump created a barrier of barrier
of hysteria
where they couldn't actually communicate
with these people so now with trump out
of the way
now they can reach out and say okay now
come over here did you say barrier of
hysteria
barrier of hysteria a barrier of
hysteria
the media went nuts i mean literally
trump's like sitting there
and the journalists are like twitching
with their pens on their notepads and
then trump
raises his hand and they go and then he
puts it back
i did i i tapped out after trump won
because i'm like i don't like him but
i'm not a psychopath i'm not gonna like
orange man
battle that's when i noticed all my
friends and family
collectively lose their minds where
every tweet
every post was orange orange orange and
i was like wow man
your guys you're like rotting your
brains are rotting
it's psychological warfare is what's
happening
with this and i don't blame these people
for having this sickness
because more powerful people who are
more gifted in like
bending the human mind have god adam
this is the crazy thing i have friends
and family members and i'm i'm like
wondering
how did they get to this point where
they used to be either completely
apolitical or
rage against the machine and now they're
100
on board with raging for the machine and
they love cnn like
i don't i don't understand how that
happened at all brilliant i really wish
we could adopt their strategies for
us so we could make tons of money and
live in the hamptons and then warn
everyone about global warming as we
keep buying beachfront properties right
i want what they're having
because i think they've realized most
people are stupid and they took
advantage of it
and they are laughing to the bank and
people don't even realize it
it seems like there's like a group a
type of person or type of mentality
that's like stuck in the matrix and
doesn't want to leave like if you tell
them look
monsanto is filling the blank the
military industry this is
this is real they're like i just i don't
my life is
too good i don't want to mess it up let
me just live out my days
and that's a lot of people there's a lot
of cowards
that we are surrounded by cowards
anymore you know um i often say things
that
trigger even people who watch even my
own content but i think most of the
resilient
people are the ones who end up sticking
around and watching sometimes people
come in they don't like what i have to
say but
i can't do anything about it i'll put it
this way though i tweeted about
um people needing to stand up for
themselves speak out and a lot of people
said they were scared of losing their
jobs
they said tim poole doesn't have kids so
he doesn't understand i've long said
i don't know i don't have kids and i
certainly respect those who are who are
you know worried that they could put
their families at risk
but i also look at all of these leftists
who are willing to sacrifice their jobs
and scream at the top of their lungs now
you know you had this
teacher who wore a black lives matter
mask and they threatened to fire her and
she said i refused to back down and she
lost her job
you had a guy taco bell same thing
there's a bunch of stories like this
where they're like i'm gonna wear my
political message even though it's
against the rules and you can't do
anything about it but
society is accepting of it you know why
though
because squeaky wheel gets the grease
true
most people don't like wokeness if most
people just
said okay fine whatever i'll speak up
then it would be the exact same for the
right as it is the left
you know i was never political until in
2020 when i was like that's it i have to
say something because people are
continuously not saying anything
i am not pc i am not like worried about
your feelings
frankly i don't care like get a pair of
balls
put your big boy pants on and let's go
to town i had all brothers like everyone
acts like a woman on her period without
a chocolate bar
and it's making me insane i'll tell you
why i don't know if you're allowed to
youtube's going to be like that but she
was right
and if i don't have a chocolate bar i
act exactly like these people do
ask my husband he will open the door
throw a chocolate bar at me and slam it
don't run away i think
the problem is there is some validity to
the rage and that is that we
kind of do live in a patriarchy i've
been thinking a lot about this our
father who art in heaven
it's like the whole christian religion
is based off my my heavenly father like
there's a
divine master
you guys don't function without us men
are the warriors men are our strength
and women
are the empathy and compassion and the
caregiving
we have our roles and our roles are
equally as awesome and i don't see it as
a patriarchy
i i see it as you're willing to go out
there and slaughter animals and hang it
off my balcony and
skin it and feed me then you know what
you deserve
some some respect and so do i because
i am the life giver even though i kind
of got cheated out of that one
but i am the life giver so i i don't
know i i see us as very equal and if you
look
through our history there's a lot of
celebration of women
i think we just choose not to see it so
we could be mad ian you need to
understand
um women um have been the pro have
always
women have always been the primary
victims of war
says hillary clinton women lose their
husbands their fathers their sons in
combat so heartbreaking
that's an actual quote from hillary
clinton oh that's circulating let me let
me read you this question
hillary clinton said women have always
been the primary victims of war
women lose their husbands their fathers
their sons in combat
now this was considered to be pretty
funny by a lot of people because it's
like dude those people died
like defending you're not the victim
like those people who died are the
victims
but i'll put it this way first of all
snopes says the ratings is
true she actually said it patriarchy
so while the men go off and die and the
women are victims because the men
sacrifice themselves to save the women
the men were the ones it was the
patriarchy
i just think that patriarchy is this
idea used to
generate support for some kind of
movement that gives someone power it's
that simple it's like
the idea that men are secretly
dominating
society like it's specifically men and
not women like men are trying to control
the women
and i do see that like really where were
the complaints from the women on the
titanic when they were the only ones
allowed to board the life ships
and all of you guys with your male
privilege were sent into the icy waves
to die
i didn't hear anything about patriarchy
women were the divine
we were protected by our men there's a
reason
because men are savages so we find good
men to protect us from the savage men
and i think this utopia people have in
their brain that people are
good and are going to protect you is
stupid
and it's it's unattainable it's never
going to happen
except the yin and the yang there's a
lot of evil
and we have the divine masculinity to
protect us ian think about the noble
rooster
yes the cockrell the mighty cockroach
the rooster will run into a predator
that it knows will kill it
at it yells out a warning to the
chickens who run and hide
and then it runs full speed to the
predator knowing it's gonna die
to save their lives yeah those chickens
got a matriarchy going on but hold on
do you know what happens if there's no
rooster and the chickens aren't doing
their thing they just get run up and
mauled by the predators
it's so we we actually had to deal with
this i know i'm making a kind of a joke
about chickens
but we were we were you know talking to
uh farmers and people who are chicken
experts about
just opening up the coop for the
chickens to come out and do their thing
and they were like yeah as long as you
have a rooster
i was like oh well we don't we we
actually didn't realize we had one at
the time but we didn't have a full grown
rooster
you can't you need you need that that
that uh
you need the rooster who defended the
villages exactly the women were the
warriors when their men were out
fighting to protect the divine feminine
and the children
if anyone came to that village you know
f around and find out that is what
happened like
try her try that woman at some point
what it seems like
some men or some people decided let's
build a system where men are in control
so that if
stuff hits the fan we can protect the
women so like they still
won't let you think you're in control
women are the most highly manipulative
creatures on this earth the fact that
you guys walk around thinking you've
oppressed us
as all we've done is legit chess pieces
with you simpletons i mean we love you
she's right
of college students are female right now
and they're saying they're the ones who
are oppressed
they're the ones who have the college
degrees and are starting to make more
money if you look at the gender wage gap
it's not even
real and yet men are just like okay and
they're trying to pass laws that keep
empowering women
yeah it goes it goes back it goes deeper
than america every king
had a really really smart manipulative
wife or like six of them
yeah and you are gonna be kicked out of
the club because you've just exposed
their secrets
yeah the secrets none of you were my
friends
you guys are evil and vindictive and
manipulative
and that's why i don't hardly have any
friends it was very hard to find
some that didn't do it back it's true
girls aren't nice
vicious we are not nice and i have long
said that women are the neck that turns
the head this is 100
remember in ancient rome where he's like
we will murder you all if you gossip and
they're like ha ha
we will continue no i haven't heard that
story
yeah they're like we will continue to
just i have friends that catfish
married couples men just to make them
divorce
and took joy in it and they didn't even
know and then tell me later and i'm like
girl you
are messed up we're mean look at this
ian guy he's all like we're actually in
charge i'm sorry i was just concerned
with the system
like there are individual bouts of
craziness on all sides but
saying that god is a man is crazy to me
i was about to let loose
god made adam and was like oh man what a
mistake i can
yeah god made adam first and then a
woman came out of adam it's like all
patriot all
man dominated and it was written by
dudes and uh he said i can do better so
he made
better well this is what would you look
at think about political power
would you rather be the face sitting
beneath the sword of damocles everyone
knows who you are knows who to come
after
or the shadow power behind it the
financiers i like the shadow power i
like the strategist
women don't both position we don't want
to sit there
men are the ones the proud peacocking
look at my feathers i'm so great and
women are like i'm in the shadows
plotting your demise and you don't even
know it actually but but let's like to
to be honest to be real
i wouldn't say they're playing the
demise obviously it's a joke but they
are planning their
comfort saying you know he's gonna he's
gonna for the longest time
you have this system where some women
felt it was oppressive
and in some ways it was there was social
enforcement like
women typically didn't have jobs so it
was hard for those who did
but they also didn't have to go to i
don't know petroleum rigs and lose their
arms or go wait around in sewers
pulling rat kings from that's why they
didn't want to vote they're like we
don't want
in that crap like there was a whole
bunch of women that were like we don't
want
part of this garbage that these idiots
are in
you used to have to be in some places uh
uh
in order to vote you had to be signed up
for the fire brigade
things like that and so if you ask
modern
leftists they'll tell you oh that was
all propaganda take away women's rights
to vote and everything
so they wouldn't get it but they're
actually women who are like you mean i
have to sign up for the fire brigade i
don't want to do that let them take care
of it
it used to be that service guaranteed
citizenship
to a certain degree right if you wanted
the right to vote there was some
responsibility expected in your
contribution to the community
and just it started to erode it used to
be that voting came with
responsibilities and eventually said
universal universal suffrage you know
you just vote everybody votes
now that's been exploited to a great
degree and my opinion's actually been
shifting on it a bit
especially after i saw jon stewart and
this is an old article where he said
that we should jon stewart said we
should bring back the draft in some form
because people have lost their sense of
community he wasn't saying like military
draft
he was effectively saying service
guarantee citizenship do something for
your community
to prove you care about it and then you
know he i don't tie it to voting
i still love john because he's not
annoying he went away and he was like
i'm not going to be like every other
celebrity on twitter look at how
annoying i am i'm all know it
like shut up i love that guy be funny
back at the 20 bill man just be funny
and that's what he is he's a brilliant
brilliant man but yeah
women aren't victims and when you don't
think of yourself as a victim
it's just not there i don't i don't see
it because
i'm no one's victim i go in the rooms
and i command them
like i'm not like oh i'm not in charge
here there's a man
like i've never felt that way and once a
chick feels that way
it's a self-fulfilling prophecy yeah
that's for sure that's why the crt
stuff bothers me yeah i don't think that
people are victims
but it does seem like the system was set
up by men
to empower give men like a foothold
with the whole god as a man men were
strong the the venetian patriarchy
was like all about the the old or the
wealthiest man would control the
family's money and run the city
so when you put a man at the top of the
hierarchy who does he have behind him
who is he supporting who is he pulling
up with him he's pulling up his family
dude my man goes out and hacks down
trees and drags
300 pound logs across a field and if i
commanded him to do something for me and
it was reasonable he would do it 100
and i love it we're equal
but i know that like he would die for me
this like powerhouse would
put himself first like i feel great over
here i'm a queen
and who uh who did they kill in the
french revolution
well the king and the queen exactly yeah
gender doesn't
no look look look uh i certainly think
it's obvious that sexism
has existed for a long time and
certainly there's been institutional
misogyny in many ways and we've overcome
those things but to act like women were
powerless
look at cleopatra she floated egypt
longer than it should have been floated
with the power
between her legs she was like wait a
minute i can manipulate
all these julius caesar i think marc
antony
like she was going for it and she
egypt would have fallen years before but
she was cunning and she was smart and
they say she wasn't even that hot
she just knew what to do yeah she killed
her sister i think that was
her sister was trying to kill her so she
had her killed herself she was well
she was a direct descendant of alexander
the great's
uh second and commit or first in command
and they inbred the whole time so i'm
sure something was going crazy because
they all kept it in the family so they
were like greek that's why when
everyone's like cleopatra was this color
i'm like cleopatra
was great okay let's just be real
am i wrong that that we live in like a
patriarchal
yes christianity is like pictures you
have been brainwashed
by a bunch of weak idiots that want me
to be a victim but am i
not am i right is it true that
christianity is patriarchal
i don't see the catholicism is
patriarchal i think the answer to that
is yes
okay look eve went and she did what she
wanted
she was like i'm gonna do what i want
and then the dude suffered for it just
like my husband does
every day when i make decisions right
so i don't find it like the patriot i
don't know i just look at the world
differently
and once you do like you just don't feel
it i think it used to be
a little sucky but like i walk around
every single day
like armed and i feel good
the great equalizer on me i'm just like
whatever
i'm powerful i don't like it sounds like
you're saying that
men sort of planned this yeah but it it
i just don't see that i think when you
look at
we talked about this in a bunch of our
dating segments if you have a hundred
men
and one woman your civilization is in
serious danger if you have 100 women and
one man
you'll actually your civilization will
probably thrive because you can have a
lot more kids
that natural component of human
existence means there's always going to
be a bias in favor of protecting women
as more valuable
just like the rooster sacrificing
himself if you have 100 men and 100
women
you can sac you can lose 99 men in
battle and your tribe your your village
your town will survive
not not so much the other way around
that's why in like
there was a raping and pillaging it
meant to steal but they would take the
women because the women were the most
important thing
so you you you look at that from an
evolutionary perspective or
a sociological perspective and over time
you're going to see more and more
institutions rise up
solely to protect women i can certainly
imagine at a certain point it became
overbearing
and especially as we've become safer and
safer we have secured the borders of
this country or at least we did a while
ago to the point
where it's totally it's it's way safer
now you don't have to worry about
banditos coming in and
viking raiders storming the beaches and
stealing your women
so now we don't need a lot of those
protections but to act like we're more
powerless when they were the ones that
were basically
the reason for the can we make this
nerdy game of thrones
cersei lannister in season one or two
coward in the red keep as all the men
fought
and she was scared oh my god stannis is
gonna come kill me
that diabolical scheming broad near the
end you knew who was in power she killed
her husband she did all this
horrible crap to everyone yeah your
brother had bastard children
everything wrong that happened in king's
landing was because of her and then she
sat on the iron throne like
yep i did it so who was in power ian
who wasn't using game of thrones it was
seriously cersei was running
until those stones smashed her head in i
mean it was her dad
until season eight destroyed all her
life
was like i should have come out it's
just a big troll like me and chad
it's just a troll it's all a lie i'm
blackpilled there was never any books he
ran out of ideas they got a wretch on it
yeah
they can do that just rewrite season
five six and seven well it's
it's like there's there's a show called
uh a full metal alchemist you've ever
heard of it
i've heard of it i've heard of it it's
an anime so uh
the way the way they do they use the way
they do anime is like someone will write
the comic version
and then they'll start animating you
know a month so
like they're on chapter 10 they're
making episode one of the show
and so the the comic is always ahead of
the show in this instance the comic
stopped and the show kept going
and then they later came back and redid
a new branch of the show with the new
storyline so
if they decide to redo seasons seven and
eight with like the new fixed writing
cgi like when they make like ol or young
cr
uh kurt russell and uh not avengers
snake polisk ant-man not ant-man the
really cool ones
the with stupid guardians of the galaxy
yes
yes i always forget that i have like a
little hate in my heart i'll tell you
guys off-camera
who's uh who's who played the guy in
ant-man the old guy i don't even see it
i can't remember this oh
uh oh you're gonna talk about it yeah
wasn't he the one that got throat cancer
from
cunnilingus oh what wasn't he married to
catherine zeta jones oh that's michael
douglas yes
they de-aged him in ant-man oh wow he's
like a young version and
and in the avengers there's like a
really like a 20 year old version
and i thought it's pretty good so they
could do that for game of thrones
problem fix we're good
just give me like a stick figure
animation explaining the fixed version
of it i'm satisfied
like here's the quick synopsis we picked
the storyline i'm sure
jon snow can say something besides i
don't want it she's mcqueen
dude they should have brought ned stark
back i mean come on guys use magic
usually
bring him back he's reunite the starks
that would have been the best when they
stole danny's dragons in the houses of
the undying she had visions of him
without his head and rob stark with a
wolf on his head and they didn't show
and i was like damn that would have been
real cool
anyway i'm sorry i took us way off
patreon
we were actually talking about um like
at some point the media and so i pulled
up this tweet from glenn greenwald i
have no idea when
i was planning on segwaying to this but
we went to game of thrones would have
been real
so anyway let's just rewind and then
segue to this
uh tweet from glenn greenwald absolutely
yes so uh glenn's great he tweeted
however shockingly tiny and minuscule
you think msnbc and cnn's audience sizes
it's way smaller than even that msnbc
barely has an audience on the weekends
i'm concerned their ratings are going to
fall into negatives
which shouldn't be possible i just love
the absolute
snark from glendon
so uh how many viewers do you think
msnbc gets
at 8 p.m on what is it what is this uh
sunday like how many how many viewers
you think okay prime time
not good i'm gonna go into a couple
hundred six million
six million is that too many wow that's
so
generous from the next check this out um
fox news
total viewers is 1.2 million sunday at 8
pm life liberty and levin
124 000 viewers between the ages of 25
and 54. that means most of their viewers
like 1.1 million are over the age of 54.
cnn gets 473 000 viewers
above the age of 50 55 and older and
only 78 000
25 to 54 and msnbc
gets 49 000 people in the key demo
you know what's crazy is we don't even
do a show that day and our clips do
better that
my crappy reality tv shows
destroyed these people and that was back
in the day
wow wow how pathetic
why did they like have so much power who
is propping them up
who's the puppet i'm trying to figure
out i'm feeling pretty good
you should but you should also feel
pretty scared
they're gonna come for you no i it's
like um
what was i was like they're a withered
and drying
you know like husk yeah let's like hey
i'm going to destroy you and i'm like
dark crystal
like yeah they're they're sexy suck out
life force
that's like yeah or watch dark crystal
am i
ages ago yeah when i was like so when i
saw lord of the rings
so they're like smeagol yes and the
precious is their ring
and and we got it we we we have the
views it's more decentralized
you know there's a bunch of different
channels that get tons of views
but what you know it's you know it's
amazing key demographic this is the main
issue right so
almost all of viewers for fox msnbc and
cnn are 55 and older
no disrespect to them but what do you
think that means in 10 20 years
yeah they're they're they're they're
done it's over
well that's why uh all the
big tech is trying so hard because they
know that they've brainwashed all these
children and that
tick tock is where they get their news
we're so pathetic
we're on tick tock i am not on tick tock
we got clips going up on tick tock
really yeah so uh i thought that's
commie chyna stuff what are you doing
fighting back on the battlefield i guess
so we we put up we put up clips
everywhere
and i don't blame you if we can put
clips up from this show on platforms
like tik tok
good then the younger people who are
there i actually think it's mostly older
people
to be completely honest but maybe not
completely there's a lot of older people
on it
are there filters i don't know oh like
those
beauty filters that's where all old
chicks like me were like oh hey i'm
22 again we should put a clip up with
beauty filters one day yeah
dude ian has like 17
did no but we we we i was thinking about
this you know a lot of people have been
like tim why won't you quit youtube
because they're censoring people and i'm
like
it's a massive battlefield why would we
give up ground that we didn't lose yet
you know
people ask me all the time while i'm
still on facebook because i say things
they're like how are you still here i'm
like
don't know for one and for two i like
built this crap
i don't want to lose it you build
something you don't want to just bounce
ride it into the ground darling yeah i
mean we're setting up the website
yeah hiring people to do news fully
expecting youtube will eventually give
us the boot
yeah but until until then let's use as
leverage as much as we can from these
networks and keep pushing back
otherwise just like walking away come on
youtube it's
tim cast they're good folks
i actually think it's bigger than that i
think that we need to make conservatism
and these good right-wing ideas cool
and that means putting them on platforms
like tiktok they are cool
that's why all the punk rockers and
weirdos like us
are like on the side now we are the cool
ones
did you but did you see bad religion do
that like weird pro alt-right song
no i every time people afford me these
cringy songs they're like you're gonna
love it i'm like yeah no i have a life
and then i don't watch it if there's a
cat that's it's on
or a chicken check it out like the
reason the ratings are in the gutter for
for msnbc worse than cnn
is that they they they excised their
legitimate audience
for orange man bed they were so
desperate to get ratings that they were
like let's keep saying trump sucks
well let's say you know a few years ago
they had a hundred thousand key demo
viewers
and 75 000 are rational moderate people
like us
they went so insane they lost all of
them but they gained
half a million to a million trump
derangement syndrome people now that
trump is gone
their whole brand was we're the
anti-trump
there's no one left to watch with no
trump these punk rockers
it's the same thing for decades you've
had you have some bands
who have built themselves up like we are
the anti-establishment the war machine
is bad
yeah and then all of a sudden they find
themselves on the winning side
they find themselves saying the same
things as walmart.com
and they're like if we come out and say
they're wrong
our audience that we've built will hate
us
you know what i was kind of scared when
i started
saying things and you know what i got
every libertarian
and conservative person just came and
bought avon for me and i'm like what
is going on like dudes dudes we have bug
guards so everyone's buying
spf and this and that i'm like this is
amazing so yeah i got cancelled by the
left
and my my fellow i guess patriots
are very supportive i'm sure you guys
are finding that out
it was the exact opposite of what i
thought was going to happen
and then they can't fire me because i'm
independent and all they want to do is
fire me so we we went to uh a skate park
somebody somebody super chatted us they
were like tim go to wakefield skate park
it's like in the dc area
so we went there and first of all let me
just say like wow that it's falling
apart
like the ramps are collapsing and i'm
like some little kid's gonna fall
anyway there was graffiti and it said
black lives matter
like some some young teenage kids
skating at a skate park
were like i'm going to vandalize
property with the corporate message from
amazon.com
starbucks made me do it yeah right it
was like the weirdest thing i was like
imagine you go to the skate park and
like some kids like he walks up to he's
got spray paint he's like
walmart.com and i'm like okay dude we
were all like
you know it would be cool that spray
paint tool
yeah tool kicks ass you know sorry
people use like that people just do like
vandalize
like to break to do do damage i mean a
lot of kids would like spray paint a
name or something
but you typically would go to the skate
park and they would write swear
words and draw dicks and stuff like that
don't you miss the days where people
watch beavis and by head and we had to
worry about kids laying in oncoming
traffic on the highway that to me was
way more peaceful and better than what's
happening now what happened
i encouraged the internet the internet
like
displayed some some the truth of what
humanity is
the mask has slipped we're all
sociopaths you know you know what i was
thinking about i was thinking about this
i'm like i'm 35 man
i just don't understand these kids these
days i know right like there was there
was never
no but like when i was 15 like i would
go
and and be like that thing i saw on the
tv about us holding hands that's what
i'm going to spray paint
we were just spray painting dixons we
weren't raised on our phones i didn't
have a cell phone until i was
21 years old and i moved to new york
city after i won top model
so i didn't have this like oh it's my
phone and
every moment in my phone like it is
pretty cool but you could put it down
i heard that babies are being born with
their necks
arced forward from people staring down
at their phones this could be
they're getting spurs in their necks the
babies the new yeah
creation of human is is being born
different because of the way people
stand i've heard
ah next spur is okay dude it's the borg
you know the board from start that
happens fast you always say borg i feel
like we're
it's a zerg like someone's kerrigan the
popper me
puppet master it's a poor queen like
starcraft yeah no the the borg has a
queen who is like
who is hierarchically above all of the
rest of the world i respect
track i was never into the zerg heavy
here's the general story of the borg is
that they were a regular humanoid race
who started incorporating different
medical technologies into themselves
cybernetics
until they linked their brains and then
instantly became a hive they could hear
everything all at once and they worked
in unison and all of their minds became
one mission
and we got these kids they're on these
phones and they're getting the corporate
messages and they're like yes
yes spray paint corporate message dude
you want to talk about being in the
matrix if one agent sees you
and then everyone else knows that you're
there that's like the mind
can mind melting it's like uh uh so uh
you know luke right he's been on the
show
yes he was in we were in germany
together and someone saw him in a
photograph like
he was like walking a different
direction from someone else and so they
accused him of
being a nazi what he's walking down the
street
and then someone points at him and yells
nazi and then random people get up
run up to him start punching him and
beating him and this other guy max like
this random german journalist max who's
like just a regular guy
these people just get up out of nowhere
and it's like you were saying like the
agents
one agent sees you and then all of a
sudden the other people just like turn
into agents
and then start attacking you that's like
what it is i wish they'd do that to
pedophiles bad people never get punished
oh right they're like buy them learjets
and give them money and i'm like wait a
minute and then luke's just hanging out
and they'll and the anchor person on tv
goes
that's a conspiracy theory oh okay
you're like hey look at the story but
this guy and then they're like you're a
conspiracy theorist
that's not true i'm so tired of humanity
can i be honest with you guys
yeah everyone out there i hate 95
of you i'm bilbo baggins on my property
i have the sign that says we don't want
any more
visitors well wishers or distant
relations like get away so this is bilbo
after returning from defeating i just
want to see mountains again i hate these
people
he was traumatized i mean billboard he
was surrounded by simpletons he's like
they haven't even seen the world
like most americans yeah we've seen the
world yeah
i mean i lived and worked in south
africa i almost died in russia i lived
out of italy and worked on a visa where
same thing in france i mean these people
have
all these big opinions on the world in
america and they haven't gone anywhere
i saw it once on instagram it's like
okay
i think people people are losing their
minds because of living in their phones
yes because they don't have real world
experiences
so let's let's let's uh do a w we're
doing a weird segue show today but this
one um i'm greatly offended by
i don't understand that actually i'm
super not offended by this
there's a guy named ali london who has
come out as trans korean
and he got surgery i guess i don't know
if he got surgery but his eyes like
so uh um i thought it was funny because
it's like the supermodel fox lift
is that what it's called yeah all those
[ __ ] i don't want to be a jerk but girl
we all know ben shapiro says live your
truth ali
and then people are making fun of him so
this guy ali london says
this is my new official flag for being a
non-binary person who identifies as
korean
thank you for the overwhelming support
it was so hard for me to come out as
them they core ian this guy's trolling
for like sure he's saying his pronouns
are core and
ian i think he's great
that's like all these people that come
to the italian
uh christmas party at mamas and they're
like oh lasagna hey we're part of the
family we're like hey
and they are part of the family only
they're not look at it look at this
this sweetie put up he penned it my
transition story
and how i became korean you know what i
find really funny about this the reason
why this one
really really like i l first of all i'm
all for it um i think everybody should
want to be korean
of course um you know so i'm like i'm
sitting here like all right but
it's just i don't know if he's being
honest if it's a big prank it probably
is
but the idea that someone who's a white
british guy
wants so desperately to be korean and
he's like he does a video where he's
like
oh like oh my god i'm like dude i i
actually my mom would make bulgogi when
i was growing up he wants to be korean
more than i do i'm actually part korean
and i
don't even speak the language at all and
this is some white dude in london who
like
wants to be more korean it's an identity
crisis it's not real
and people are mentally ill we're all
like
this is a mental illness crisis
that we've never seen anything like this
before
it's like they've opened all the doors
of
you know insane asylums it's like the
scarecrow and the batman movie when he's
just released the drug on the people
that is what the phone's done
tmc says british influencer identifies
as korean after 18
surgeries to look like bts singer i'm
sorry man this is a guy
he's committed i i think
there's a lot of people who who like
there's transracial is like
clearly it's been a thing for a while
with rachel dolezal and people like sean
king where they're just claiming to be a
certain race when they're clearly not
and uh anyway so you get people like
this and it's it's the weirdest thing to
me because i'm like
i i had a bunch of like white
nationalist dudes telling me that i
wouldn't understand
the alt-right because i have no identity
they're like tim poole
is like mixed race so he doesn't
actually have anything you mean you're
an american mot
like most of us like most people like
how many people are like i'm irish and
it's like well you're also german and
italian
a bunch of stuff i'm italian uh lebanese
irish and scottish but i was raised by a
full
italian woman whose parents and family
were all off the boat
and i i i feel italian because you were
raised italian but
i ain't i am an american mutt and when
we go to other countries what are you oh
i'm irish they're like you were
oh you were born in ireland they're like
no and they're like god americans are
stupid you guys are so
dumb yup well um what do we say to this
guy
that guy's like crazy and amazing all at
the same time
i'm here i'm i'm for it because um
i don't i i i we might get in trouble
for even talking about it but i don't
see the difference between this or any
other identity
like if you just want to assert i think
it was zooby who was saying that
race is a social construct because if
you said he made a good point about this
i i don't think it's fair to say
completely but he said if you told
people that obama was white
they would say you're nuts if he said he
was black they would say of course he is
even though he's the exact same amount
of white as he has black
you know so probably to people in africa
they look at obama as
probably more white because he's not you
know not the same as them
he's he's mixed race that's a really
good point by zubi
so you look at something like this and
he's like okay well
gender like biological sex hard physical
differences between the biological
biological sexes but you could have
somebody born in korea
who could probably pass for white or
someone who's born in france who could
pass for korean
i've i've known a lot of people in my
life who are just like regular white
people and they were like french
and they looked like they had some asian
in them like no completely white
oh yeah my my husband has like i thought
he had native american and it turns out
he's full viking he went and got a dna
test i was like that totally makes sense
you
nordic giant the celts were all over the
place they came from like the
the north northwest europe and they went
to like east asia they went to like
anatolia
and past turkey they went down to spain
like they were everywhere
we're all humans and colonizing is
simply conquering and that's what human
beings do we kick each other's asses and
we take each other's stuff
that is what war is so when people are
anti-war i'm like yeah i'm anti-war and
when you don't gloat how you're taking
all their stuff
so what we've been in the middle east
forever congratulations everyone we
took all their things just say it that's
why you're there
you know what i mean but with this thing
remember the cat lady with all the
surgeries and everyone made fun of her
for years
she was ahead of everyone there's this
like social life
that turned herself into a cat she
was the original so well there was the
there was the
trans cat tran trans female cat i i'm
genuinely trying to get this correct
there was an individual who was born
male who got
surgery to look like a tiger and then
came out as transgender as well
and then it's a sad story ultimately
ended up committing suicide
so i i think one of the issues is that
people who have
uh in many respects an identity crisis
and they can never
figure out who they are i don't think
that in many of these circumstances like
this guy look at this photo right here
from from what's his name
london ali ali london whatever this face
is making where he's like doing his
fists
it's a caricature of korean people like
i don't think he's ever actually gone to
korea and met a korean person
because they don't act like these
cartoon characters there there was a a
viral tick tock
where a guy was talking to
the camera and he was making these
really creepy motions
where he was like bouncing like this as
he talked and doing like that
acting like a cartoon character from a
disney movie you know what i think it is
i think a lot of people when they grow
up and they're
completely entrenched in seeing some
kind of behavior their brain
adds that to like this is what adults do
that's how they act
so when you get a guy who's doing these
face things he spends too much time too
much time watching
fiction like this caricature of of
korean pop culture where they
it's not how people act nobody acts that
way could you imagine if americans were
walking around like n sync and dancing
and singing with each other all the time
it's not like real life okay but they
they think it is
so now he's like in order to be normal i
have to be that
how old is he 24 i think okay
and this is our generation's fault we
failed the children people our age had
kids
and we told them all this bull crap you
could be anything johnny you're a winner
every moment anything you dream and this
is the result
we had a chance between 2006 and 9 to
set the record straight and get people
to unify
but then we gave power to obama and let
him act like the new messiah everyone
it's almost like
you know i never see this people laugh
for me to speak out against to be fair
what do we do mccain
it's like it was just it was awesome
power to a president was the problem
because we shouldn't have done that
yeah she was fun to watch it was like
giving we gave power to a president for
the for the last time like it was the
bit
last straw you cannot give power to one
guy to run this country
it's too much of a big of a job well i
think i think americans did come
together and then they vilified
everyone for doing it in 2016 they
all voted for donald trump except for me
i didn't do it
but my gay cousin did and so did his
partner
and you know what i voted for trump in
2016. 2016 and
in uh this last election my gay cousin
hi
if you're watching made a gaze for trump
sign all
rainbow and sparkly put a flood light on
it in the south side of chicago it was
like
bring the hate crime baby bring the hate
crime he was like watching out the
window like i'm gonna get them
and i'm so proud of him because he's all
like i reject
lgbtq community it's been hijacked i
reject
broken glass and all this stuff that
they're telling me is okay and burning
down buildings and i'm like my
cousin is so based i was very proud of
him that's punk rock
yeah raised mormon gay as gay can be
and was gay for trump i love you it
feels like
we had a chance in 2006 to nine again
these years for me it was very uh
there's a growing period where we could
have ended the war and we didn't and now
the young generation is like oh
this is okay then i'm just i don't care
about anything
because if that's okay then this world
has no meaning
i wanted to end it yeah i was like was
it day two
yeah get out of there that that's what
one of the things that woke me up and
that's when i started digging i was like
wait he wanted to end the
war that obama lied to me about and then
i researched and found out it was all
lie
you know you know i think you're right
about they see the war
and they're like you know nothing
matters my view of it is
you grew up in a world where like you're
literally born into a country at war and
occupying the middle
east and it's it's like how do you argue
morality
how do you for for all of us who
experience 9 11 there was a shock to our
emotions
and so they made that case and a lot of
people bought into it and a lot of
people eventually said we've had enough
this was wrong it should never have
happened the aumf needs to be
officially rescinded but for these
people who were born into it the united
states has
always been the country that just does
what it wants goes over there
and just kind of screws it up so what
happens is their moral compass is just
like
a corkscrew it's not pointing in any one
direction it's just like
nothing matters i can be anything i'm a
tiger korean and i'm
you know the the moon is made of bricks
burn building
like crazy things matters right extract
wealth from the system but think about
that like they're killing over there the
kids who grew up in a country they were
like a lot of these young kids who are
now
out with antifa they may have been uh i
mean
it's been it's been almost 20 years
since 9 11.
so you have these kids who are
like toddlers when it happened with no
memory with no experience of it
being born into a world where they're
told over and over again the u.s
takes what it wants so what do they do
they walk around with bricks they smash
windows they take whatever they want
who's gonna tell them they're wrong
it's because we told parents they
couldn't punish their children anymore
i'm not for abusing children but when i
was bad
my parents and my old italian grandma
she would take off her church shoe get
that hard heel and be like
come up and i was like oh don't do that
again i learned a lot of lessons
what was it called chankla that's right
yeah
the the flip flop from the grandma and
cheese it was not a flip-flop it was a
hardcore hardwood
the mexican catholic italian catholic
she was not messing around she's like
jesus saw
he saw what you did i'm like wooden
spoon with a hole in the middle
so it'd leave a the welt would grow
where the hole was but i didn't get it
much i was like the first generation
where you can
get it much just because i didn't speak
up
i played within the lines but also like
you're saying we were
part like the beginning of the
generations of people did not hit your
kids not that i don't advocate for
hitting kids i don't like it i don't
think he should
but like i i was like my brother i'm
calling child service you know that kind
of like
i didn't have that my grandma was born
in the 1920s she was rosie the riveter
her brother
served in world war ii and was in a
concentration camp as a pow with like
uh the tattoo all of that she was having
none of that you're calling dcfs
that didn't exist in my house and it was
never to be said
and i lived think about this way you get
a kid
who grows up and we're not talking about
abusing kids we're talking about
a spanking yeah no no abuse is horrible
but if i tell my mom she's the b word
and i did
and then my mom's like what bop which i
deserved and then i sat there like oh
maybe i should never call my mom a page
again and that's what i did
it's i think there's a line i think
there's a lot of research that shows
that
corporal punishment i guess they call it
is not particularly effective but i have
to question
what's the research going to show on
when you have a bunch of kids who grew
up without punishment at all
or it was very much like okay okay honey
okay i'll buy you ice cream if you calm
down
what's gonna happen to those people
they're older and they're communists and
they're throwing bricks through windows
true like when i went to school when we
had problems with each other
we met behind the tennis courts and i
mean bloodbath
fought it out like there was
consequences to like
things people don't do that anymore
there's no
like boxing matches anymore i guess you
just go into dueling
near a city and break out a building and
light it on fire and loot your
nearest nike could you imagine being
back in the day and it's like
you know someone's tweeting at you and
then you're like sir i challenge you to
a duel and it's like we're gonna end
this twitter flamewar once and for all
someone dies how crazy would you get
like you have like experience and it
goes up if you win the duel
no just pistols at dawn twitter beef
twitter of beef be
ended that's right no sir i will not
debate you pistols
that's why i think everyone should be
locked and loaded we should all open
carry every single american citizen how
many people will be like you know what
i'm going to carjack that car
no because everyone in that car is
locked and loaded i
i truly believe that we've fallen this
is the map
this is the craziest thing to me how
many how many times i've seen like on
twitter
there's a dude who's trying to violently
rob
someone with like aggravated assault and
then someone comes out
like there's a video where it's like a
guy draws a gun on someone and then a
woman pulls a gun from her purse and she
shoots him
and i see people on the left being like
she didn't have to kill him
you know she could have done this and
it's like that's the mentality that i
think leads to ruin
yeah i love criminals the criminals who
are attacking
and oppressing should not have been
harmed in any way and it's like well
hold on first of all
i wish it didn't happen but if you walk
up to someone point a gun
to their head and someone puts you down
because of it like we're trying to stop
that violence and we're acting in
defense of others but how many stories
have we heard where it's like a dude's
running from the cops and he pulls a gun
how about that guy uh in in atlanta
he turns the taser and fires it at the
cops and so the cop fires in defense and
they're like arrest the cop
oh wow that's i saw a post i saw a post
on facebook
some guy said uh chauvin is finally
being locked up
and it's about time justice doesn't
always happen blah blah blah
and i responded with don't forget about
the chaos the violence and the
destruction if it wasn't for
the terror and the violence those jurors
may have actually let chauvin go
never forget never forget it is better
that
10 innocent people suffer than one
guilty person escape
so saith otto von bismarck and the
person liked it
i was i was trying to make a point like
i was trying to make a point that like
do you see yourself for who you are it
is better that ten
guilty persons escaped than one innocent
suffer but the left today is absolutely
adopted they would love the innocent to
suffer if it means one guilty person
you're asking people to look in a mirror
at their true like
in the never-ending story when atreyu
has to
face his true self in the mirror gate
and he looks
and it drives some men mad i've spent 20
years in therapy i've been looking at my
reflection for a long time
i think a lot of people should be doing
this and if they did
maybe our world wouldn't be so horrible
but no one does
because if we train everyone just lie to
yourself and say you're a good person
there's hardly any good people like
humanity what we want to do
every day we want to be selfish i cook
delicious food
and there's a crispy piece of chicken
and my selfish brain goes i want that
i don't want to give that to my husband
and then i have to override that selfish
worthless behavior and give him the good
crispy chicken and i'm like
that shouldn't be so hard but it's hard
i want the chicken you're a good person
right that is that good where my first
thought is i want
everything good for me good good
subjective because you think about it
and you decide to share
the definition of courage is not being
fearless
right it's overcoming your fear so you
look at these other people and they
don't have that self-control of course
we're all selfish inside
what we're seeing with the latest
iteration of this this mainstream left
is overt authoritarianism look at look
at what happened in
minnesota these people genuinely thought
that it was better
that all of the innocent people of the
city suffer with bricks through windows
and fires
with armed men escorting jurors in
terror into the building
so that one man would not escape but we
as more libertarian types take the
opposite view
it is better that the guilty people
escape to preserve the production of the
innocent we are ned stark and that lost
his head
i think it was ben franklin who made a
really important point it might have
been jefferson about why we must
err on the side of defending liberty and
that means guilty people escape
because if at some point the innocent
person knows that they will not receive
justice
the system can't sustain itself because
the innocent stop participating
yep yeah you get mass non-compliance
from people who fear no matter what i do
you will attack me i will defend myself
that's why i don't like to travel that's
why this is the first
time i've traveled i don't trust even
like
a layover in a blue state i don't feel
comfortable
i'm not comfortable i'm just i'm not and
especially the system is broken
especially now that the world health
organization is saying we got to remask
again yeah what's up with that
they're like oh delta variant now
everyone's got to get your masks back on
even if you're vaccinated
no no joke they the world health
organization is saying even if you are
fully vaxxed it's time
to wear masks and it's time to socially
distance again
and the craziest report i saw and i
really have to i really have to say this
before i mention this news story
don't take any of this medical advice
always talk to your doctor and if you're
unsatisfied you get a second opinion but
always get your advice from a medical
professional
because the latest story is there are
doctors
advocating for booster shots with other
vaccines
yeah so there are people who quite
literally get the johnson and johnson
and then go get two more shots from a
different company
and that to me is insane but they're
actually now saying
apparently cnbc reporting that it may be
required that all these people get
boosters now we've they've talked about
boosters before
but now they're actually encouraging
people to mix them up that's i would not
advise that talk to your doctor that
sounds really really dangerous
we got the delta variant everybody's
freaking out
there's a variant this a variant that a
country this a country that
so here we go think of it this way
they've convinced women that injecting
botulism into their face is a good idea
and we celebrate it and everyone's
frozen like this
and everyone thinks it's this great
thing botulism in their face and then
they tell us to put silicone implants or
saline which i've done into your body i
got rid of them because they're toxic
and horrible
and they don't even tell you the
ingredients and the sack of fluid
they refuse to tell you the ingredients
and the same in the in the
in the saline or silicone they do not
list the full ingredients they will not
tell you
and then just do sand i had mystery
illnesses for like six years i got them
out of my body it turns out one was
ruptured when every doctor told me it
wasn't
so this mystery silicone ooze was
i mean if you're wondering why i'm
insane it's probably because
a mystery silicone oh so now the same
people that like
have convinced women mutilate your
bodies it's great
oh and then all this i don't trust
anyone everyone's a liar and
everything's for money
that's what i feel with with we've heard
over and over again about the variance
now you've got more lockdowns underway
australia is locking down again
how long until these blue states start
locking out again
i like three days three effing days
why aren't you so happy
i'm 50 50 on it because i certainly
think people have reached their wit's
end
boiling point yeah i mean i don't i
don't even know if the blue states can
muster up what they did
last year montana's fine we voted the
guy that
tackled the reporter like we immediately
were like that's our guy
gia forte i think is his name he like
tackled this media guy was like you
broke my glasses oh my god montana's
like he's got a grit
and put him right in so i feel he does
pretty much everything florida does
think about what that means like what
that means for where we are in terms of
the culture war
yeah it's that bad i'm for peaceful
divorce it's time
i don't think it's possible i think it's
totally possible
you think oregon will give up their
serfs in the east
the rural folk who are producing things
and provide tax revenue to the cities
i think they have to unless they want
ugliness that's all divorce i got a
divorce without a lawyer
and i took no money and i let him keep
all my crap
because i was happier without him and i
walked away
and everyone was like what i'm like nope
i hope i hope it all holds you when you
die i hate you so much
and that's how we feel about each other
so let it go everyone walk their
separate ways
in eastern oregon they voted to secede
and join idaho yeah i think that's
fantastic the state's not going to allow
it
the the federal government's not going
to recognize it they're going to
pooh-pooh it and say we don't care about
so it's not for the people
but what happens when the people there
just say we the people
have a right to to choose who governs us
we have all voted it is confirmed so as
far as we're concerned
they say bye-bye what are they going to
do send state police into these areas
and occupy it
i don't i don't know i i don't know what
i can say
i have so many thoughts but i don't want
to say i'm here
this will be interesting because these
people want to be part of america
they're not succeeding from the union
they want to join idaho right yeah so if
they keep paying federal taxes the feds
are like we don't got anything to do
with this
so oregon want to send state police to
the east to the eastern counties
to enforce what tax collection if they
say we're starting to idaho because we
voted and as far as we concerned we
recognize this
i hope they do it i hope they do they
voted for it
if we're a country founded upon the idea
that you needed the consent of the
governed
so how does the united states of any
capacity from state city
to country justify telling five counties
who voted to secede that they're not
allowed to
i think this proves to you that voting
doesn't matter
and that they don't care at all what we
say or what we feel it's just a cash
grab who knows who's in whose pockets
but
we don't matter and what we want doesn't
matter at all but i really hope they
join idaho i love idaho
it touches my state they're wonderful
people so come on
join us yeah greater idaho would be one
wonderful
french fries potatoes the state of
jefferson you've got
uh i think i think it's one or two
counties in northern colorado that want
to join wyoming i think it is
oh that's fantastic because they're like
cattle ranchers and they're like why are
we following the laws of this like blue
state you know
isn't it beautiful i i mean
two realities people in the cities are
in the hive mind
they're insane they all they're agent
smith
me me me me too they're all the same
things so
let's just guys go go be happy with
yourselves and
pat each other's backs and let us run
around
with our guns and our glory and our
pride
and i guess i don't know we'll share the
military
i don't know i i feel like uh i i i
think custody of the kids
yeah no maybe michael was talking about
that like there would be a peaceful
divorce but there would be a common
defense
yeah no it wouldn't happen if if someone
tried to leave the united states the
military would take it back
and then and occupy it yeah good luck
reinstall a governor
and like if texas tried to secede they'd
blockade the entire
texas gulf uh they'd they'd send in
military
forces to conquer and you know my
country of texas you know why wouldn't
work
well a lot of reasons would enrage
people more
so if you have 35 percent of
of of a state voting for secession from
the union
and 60 or so or 50
completely abstain and then only like 20
percent
or less you know like 15 object
the vote carries the state secession is
passed the feds come in
and then start saying we're going to
occupy and reinstall the new government
and then those uninitiated 50
who didn't care and didn't vote all of a
sudden are like what's going on they're
all angry
the best example of this is the loudoun
county schools you got critical race
theory
we're culture warriors always yelling
about the social justice warriors and
then the woke people are like well
actually
and then the regular moms are the ones
who stand up screaming like
why is this happening we don't want any
of this and it turns out the most
powerful
force was the sleeping giant the regular
people who don't care
that's the big challenge right now and i
think that's one of the things that the
government is really really terrified of
because more and more jurisdictions are
saying they want to secede from
different jurisdictions
if a state truly did say we want out
occupation in the era of social media
means
instant and rapid support for the cause
or you could see like
you know the state of washington secedes
and then china invades and then the
united states and
counters it to defend it and it's a
proxy war like vietnam and the entire
state gets leveled to the ground
the bad bad bad all around to to
separate pieces
because they could be like yeah you can
leave the united states but you're not
taking our land
everything we do from here on out is
going to be horrible
i don't think there's a beautiful
hopeful future
for any side at this point i've been
reading about like
the romans the history of the romans you
know they would send like 30 000 men to
battle
and they would all get killed in a day
oh 30 000
like the entire city would be wiped out
in a day and it would take hundreds of
years
to get back to where they had been i
think we're gonna be all right
i think because of the era of fourth and
fifth generational warfare
the i think the most like the worst case
scenario will be skirmish violence
like small pockets and then if it does
escalate to that point it will be a
somewhat peaceful divorce i say somewhat
because it's it's almost impossible to
maintain
this full level of violence just because
social media
the rapid sharing of videos and photos
now the one thing that could change that
i suppose is the pure hatred of the
other tribe which is like
it is deep right now the left the things
i see them post on reddit i'm like
the paranoid delusional reality these
people live in
it's crazy and there's no convincing
them otherwise they don't want to i have
family members and friends
who have just completely lost it and
they
they say things to me on facebook that
i'm like that's not real
like let me show you that it's not real
and they're like no it doesn't matter if
you show them it's almost like
a woman whose husband has abused her for
years
she just can't leave him and she will
protect him and
all the lies that she is like this web
of deceit that the
and to the point where she almost
believes it's like stockholm syndrome i
just
help help look at me oh a great metaphor
you're in the mud pit with them and
they're like throwing mud at you and
you're like no no no there's something
here that's really valuable
look let me show you you pull this ring
out of the mud but it's all muddy and
you throw it at them because you're like
this is it
it's this piece of information but it's
all covered in mud so to them it just
looks like you're slinging mud at them
i used to be that person where everyone
was like no no let me tell you about
trump i'm like no
orange man bad anderson cooper said
orange man bad
bad man is orange and that was me
and i didn't even watch news i had this
big opinion because i was programmed
and then i finally pulled myself how did
you get out do you remember when
um alyssa milano tweeted he is he's
literally
orange and that's part of his strategy
or something like that like she was
actually mad that he was orange
she sucks i'm sorry she sucks
how did i get out how'd you get out of
it i watched the both sides video the
real one
what's that the one that they didn't
manipulate
with reality tv editing which i
understand very much because i worked
uh also behind the scenes on reality tv
shows doing franken bites
and manipulating things to make people
say things they didn't
and when i saw that they did that to
trump what they used to do to me on tv
it was like the matrix all the code
was all in front of me and i'm like oh
my god our news is a reality tv
show and everything they they're like
how can we manipulate this for cash
do you know who was running cnn a
reality tv show producer
yeah and we had a reality tv show
president yeah look at that
yeah you have a reality tv show
contestant here
talking about everything is the truman
show
there's a conspiracy theory that the
show's not live no it was actually
recorded in 1877.
yes we went back in time
it is live because i'm really trying to
watch my mouth anybody out there
but i don't
chats and i understand them and you can
see them and then we read them no tim
it's quantum tunneling
yeah that's great yeah the joke i made
was that we we record the show after the
show comes out
we go we go back in time and then upload
it through a time vortex like
donnie darko yeah
let's read super chats my friends if you
haven't already please
tap that like button give a little
little tap to show that you like the
show subscribe to the channel share it
with your friends
if you're listening on podcasts give us
a good review and don't forget go to
timcast.com
become a member we are going to have uh
i will call it a
juicy and salacious hollywood tale how
about that god
no no yes
timcast.com members only around 11 or so
but let's read some
super chats okay what's this one
bogdanov says tim i smashed the like
button like you said and now it's asking
for child support
that's awfully quick to ask for child
support you'd imagine that would take at
least
some time all right let's see
ronan jack says third place in the
hammer throw does not a thor make
burn oh so so this is so the super chats
are from earlier in the show but
i'll fight you naked says being of
korean heritage i think it is terribly
important for tim to weigh in on the
british kid that just declared himself
to be a non-binary trans korean
even spent 150 can surgery to look the
part
i mean i'm i'm chill everybody should
want to be korean that's right you know
yeah you guys never age bring it over
here
even even uh yanme who is here who's
korean thought i was 10 years younger
than i am
isn't that beautiful yeah it's crazy and
she is
from korea north korea to be exact it's
nonsense
all right jack o'neal says will your new
paranormal show investigate cheyenne
mountain
we need to know why it takes so much
energy and air force funding yeah i
believe that is a 100
yes of course i got a private tour there
because of
military friends when they were shutting
it down
and i was like interesting you're moving
all this stuff in here shutting it down
yeah yeah i've heard that you see
phenomenon when there's rushing water
underground
underneath areas like that'll cause
electromagnetic activity
sometimes ghosts are seen in areas like
that under mountains maybe
ghosts surrender mountains i do enjoy
your brain
i was in i think i was in brazil i can't
remember exactly where i went to an
abandoned military base
and it was so creepy i i agree there's
been
some creepy crap i've seen in my life
but i've never seen like a ghost like yo
it's a baboon have you ever seen those
like floating orbs
no like balls of light that like you see
in your peripheral or anything or
sometimes they show up on cameras
i mean i used to do a lot of
hallucinogenics and i saw a lot of
things
tell me more
i stopped seeking those answers that i
always lost once i sobered up
all right all right david flores says
tim i recently purchased the i am a
gorilla t-shirt and wore it to work and
it was a big hit
of course the best shirt ever go to
timcast.com click the store oh you have
one
yeah i was actually stoked i love free
things and you gave me a free thing
they they they they really you know
darkened it
yeah i don't understand that was a
little dark yeah like you can't even see
the suit because it's a gorilla wearing
this
free shirt and i got a shirt from luke
too so
i'm double dipped i've got them nice all
right
anchor agarwal says has adrian checked
out anarchist handbook my malice or
enough already by scott horton if so any
thoughts
also what would adrian recommend for a
city person who wants to adjust to the
country
okay i have the handbook in my hotel
room and i
need to start reading it but i was stuck
into jordan peterson's book
so i'm like i'm gonna get there uh how
to adjust
you know you think that you can't adjust
you just
get over it it takes a month to learn
new habits you move out to the middle of
nowhere
i thought i was going to mentally break
where i live now because
there i think i went six months without
seeing a human being
at a certain point and i was just like
okay
but you can do it you can do anything
you want to do
but just make yourself busy man because
if you're like
unplugging from the matrix and you go
somewhere rural and you don't have
something to do you might lose your mind
you have a garden we got an important
one here
the real hydro says ian because i love
you and i'm a true friend
those glasses are too small for your
face thank you sir look at me
they're also kind of dirty i think i
don't think they're they actually
are a little too small really i had
these like round like john lennon round
ones maybe i'll get another pair of
those but it doesn't matter can you see
yeah yeah screw it there you go all
right peter watkins says ian
until you fold one and hand it to a
grieving wife of course you don't know
why that cloth is so important
the symbolism i don't know man i won't
die for a symbol
jmac says i did a ceremony flag burning
in the air force the flag is a symbol of
freedom
especially those that have fought for
the freedom or have lost people
defending that freedom
as burning goes i have the same stance
on drugs i agree with legality but not
with the morality
yeah i feel that way i don't like people
burning the flag but i respect their
right to burn their own private property
i don't like prostitution but i think it
should be legal
yeah there's a lot of challenges that
this is something interesting has
happened
because the democrats have lost the plot
i'm seeing a lot of like
a lot of people embrace religion oh i
found god
again last year agnostic for years and i
was like yep nope
uh good and evil i'm on the side of good
and it's
it's resulting in a lot of uh really i
think it's opening the door for former
liberals to actually hear legitimate
conservative arguments on why they want
certain things to be illegal like
marijuana or prostitution
and there's a lot of interesting points
that you don't you don't hear
when you're in the liberal bubble you
don't hear the real argument why would
you want marijuana illegal what's the
argument for that are you guys familiar
with that
uh i i'm not going to pretend to speak
on the actual arguments because that's
kind of the point like
i've i've never actually heard like a
real i i've heard a few of them
in recent because i'm now having more
conversations but it has to do
with like the breakdown of of society
and
community and like social cohesion look
at what happened to colorado when they
legalized weed
yeah crime went up right yeah well it's
it's like when it comes to prostitution
when it comes to
uh marijuana and these things there's
there's a limit
in first of all will it can you actually
ban them anyway otherwise people just do
it
but also with it's it's i think it's
misplaced enforcement
when we had social enforcement of hey
don't do drugs
and don't do these things like lewd
lascivious things there was social
cohesion
and that was a byproduct of it so i
think a lot of conservatives misplaced
the loss of
social cohesion seeking legal
ramifications for these you know what i
mean
like make it illegal and that will bring
back what we had before when what we had
before
we had a moral compass right yeah or at
least the facade of one where we
pretended we were better than what we
are
i think this reminds me a little bit of
how parents looked at kids who had high
self-esteem who did really well in life
and they decided that it was because
they had self-esteem and not
that they were like strong students and
good upstanding young people that they
actually had self-esteem so it's a case
of i think inverted causality i think
that's very much the same way for uh
marijuana and stuff
you know you guys can't get me anymore
but i really do appreciate the daily
wire
producing that cut of me being trolled
by the chat over michael knowles book
fine castle ie says is tim now
humiliating his chat trolls
i'm speechless next he will control her
words and her mind
like what michael knowles said in his
upcoming book now on pre-order on amazon
i didn't order it now yeah you can
actually order it right now uh
yeah michael knowles has a book i know
do you know you you're familiar with the
memes yeah
oh man people are asking about my waifu
okay moving on when you were talking
about drugs were you saying that like
back in the day
it there was social cohesion and they
were attacking drugs and now
there's no social cohesion and so a lot
of drugs are legal so people are
thinking that it's because there's drugs
are legal that we've lost social
cohesion
basically 80 years ago everybody was
like
hey man don't do these drugs and you
know don't be a prostitute and they were
all like okay
social enforcement's kind of like what
jordan peterson says about monogamy
over time society becomes less and less
cohesive yeah differentiate the internet
oh definitely it decentralizes different
communities or different things
and then you know with people saying we
need to ban these
uh these lewd lascivious and degenerate
things
to return to when our society was
actually functioning
was more functional than it is today
because this fighting is destroying us
there's an interesting point that we're
becoming as a country extremely
dysfunctional like talking about
peaceful divorce
some people genuinely believe if we have
enforcement of certain
like moral laws or whatever it will
bring us back to those points where we
had cohesion you're still gonna have
prostitution and drugs and the fun part
of
both was getting away with it now when
it's legal
what is fun about this everything's
legal
i'm like this isn't even fun i think a
lot of marijuana psychosis comes from it
being illegal like being afraid for me
i was afraid i was going to get caught
everywhere and i quit
i was like this is stupid now it was
better in la when it was legal
well what when obama was raiding
everything yeah it was shortly after
2017 it was nice all right miles kinslow
says hey guys
tim you have one legend here adrian i
remember
seeing you from america's next top model
it's amazing to see how much you've
grown
also loved your interviews with howard
stern wish you the best oh god i'm sorry
how many how did you do with howard uh i
three
i was his first celebrity guest on
sirius
and one of his last on his radio but
cool yeah i've lived a lot of life a lot
of howard stern lately
you have i've lived a lot of life i
can't stand his tds but
i still like him because i'm not a bigot
that's right
and that's what you do when you're not a
bigot
skeptic says tim can you address your
tweet thread about
the about anonymous users how is it
different than you toeing the line with
youtube's terms of service respectfully
alex
i have no idea how the youtube's terms
of service relates to the threat about
anonymous users
but we did mention this i thought it was
really funny how i tweeted
i tweeted something like stop responding
to accounts that don't use their real
avatars or names and watch political
discourse greatly improve
and that is a fact and a bunch of people
got really mad and they were like no
and then people made videos like tim is
melting down and i was like
i have 825 000 followers
i can tweet something like i pick some
fresh raspberries today
and there will be like a communist
squirrel saying something like
you're so dumb because those aren't
raspberries they're salmon berries or
something ridiculous
and if i respond they're just baiting me
into wasting my time
i have too many followers i'm not trying
to be disrespectful
it's hard to sift through so i barely
even look at the replies to my tweets
you gotta be a last worder
i was like dear twitter you are all
horrible human beings
i hate all of you you're just vile
disgusting creatures and i was like
deactivate and you know they're like
like they started coming in i was like
goodbye this is something really
interesting happened today
that greatly exemplifies why twitter is
destroying everything
so right wing watch got banned and i
tweeted we uh
we wrote up a story for timcast.com and
i tweeted you are burned by your own
fire
this is what happens when you advocate
for censorship you get what you you've
asked for
and then within a few hours they got
reinstated
on twitter i have 280 characters so i
say you got burned by your own fire
on youtube in my 25 minute video i was
like look youtube will probably
reinstate them they'll say it was a
mistake
because it's probably the algorithm
that's just doesn't matter they only get
their news from twitter tim
but on twitter without the full context
now like keith albertman's tweeting at
me and he's like what was that all about
and i was like as i explained in my you
know
20-minute breakdown of what was going on
in my opinions on these things
i gave the full context as to of course
right-wing watch is going to get
reinstated
idiots don't commit to 25 minutes of
word of course
they're like with 30 seconds or less and
throw a cat in there
carl sagan talked about it oh what'd he
say that that that except from his book
that was viral every so often where he's
like there's going to be a future where
people want sound bites
tiny sound bites 10 seconds and they're
too dumb not paying attention
and it's like that's where we're at
there's a study that came out nbc news
reported on it you get i think 67
more engagement if you insult a
political enemy
twitter is awful it's a witch hunt
it's the salem witch trials which women
were in charge of you know what happened
and i think my ancestor anne putnam was
let's pretend you're my my husband and i
thought you looked at the neighbor
bending over i'd be like she's a witch i
saw her worshiping lucifer and then i'm
like ha ha
you know they were tripping on ergot
yeah thank you they were also trying to
protect their husbands roving eyes and
she's a witch
they were all in control and the men
thought oh look we're burning witches
we're the big men and all the women are
like idiots
burning everyone we hate all right uh
speaking of witches chris brown says ian
stop it we do not live in a patriarchy
women control
and teach our children divorce rate is
what who usually gets the kid in the
divorce
who then grow up and rule yeah i
wouldn't say we live in a patriarchy or
a matriarchy but there are aspects of
patriarchal
like like relics in our society that is
because we're based on judea christian
principles
yeah all right trigger happy sjw says
adrian is the manliest person in the
room she could probably bench tim
look at those guns oh man no i'm
actually that's why i had to marry such
an alpha male so i could
finally feel like a woman that's nice
like i'm a
lady finally yeah he's fighting grizzly
bears with his bare hands
well not no no he would probably die
and then i would have to kill it and
then cry over my fallen warrior so let's
not do you guys have a plan when you're
walking together like
you you flank out to the right i'll hit
him in the front his whole thing is like
if i'm down and you have to do it he's
like babe don't
shoot me cause like i i'm like crazy i
get crazy i'm like oh my god i'm all
stressed out the anxiety and i'm gonna
be like
you know he's like you know that you
won't miss there here's a good one
angel joy says imagine taking a walk as
a child with your parents
you hear a dog growl close by you
immediately go to your dad who will
protect you
the next minute you scrape your knee and
go to your mom to kiss it
god protects yep yeah it's very daoist
i like that it's beautiful it's meant to
be man
that's what we do ben walker says ian
don't get caught up in the literal for
our father it's symbolic i recommend you
check out jordan peterson's biblical
lectures on youtube
loved by both atheists and theists at
least according to the comments
lydia was just telling me that on friday
or thursday uh friday night after the
show i was like hey you should really
check out what jordan peterson has seen
i could watch him all day all day so
good all day
long yeah and he talks about the bible
chimpanzee full of snakes
what an epic bonus he talks about the
bible
adam says montana is a terrible place
where the men are bold and the women are
cold not you adrian
and you you darn near freeze to death
you can send us envelopes stuffed with
cash and we'll send you a postcard of
glendive and some license plates
i hear colorado's nice no don't go to
colorado
it's already infiltrated everyone just
go to colorado
ghost crusader says finding out that
adrian is only a year older than me
when i would watch her on my fair brady
truly makes me want to cry
ugh i wasted my life i'm so
sorry i did too so many years
down the toilet so
when you weren't having contact with
like people what what were you doing up
in the mountains
what in the mountains yeah like there's
no people like
being more and more insane prepping for
the apocalypse every moment prepping for
the apocalypse where my husband finally
was just like
woman stop watching all this crap
what are you gonna do i'm like well what
are you gonna do he's like well if
you know s hits the fan then i engage
he's like but what are you gonna do
worrying about it all the time and then
finally
i found peace but i go outside we hike
we we have
animals i i love to watch the wildlife
we have hummingbirds flying in the
window and we're nursing them back to
life and they're like wee
it's wet i feel like snow white when it
hits the fan
and you guys are in your bunker and then
he comes out of the bathroom and he's
like you know wiped his butt he's gonna
be like
i was wrong i'm sorry thank you for
everything you've done yeah no
my my husband knows i run the ship and i
know i know he
puts the ship together there you go that
is what we do teamwork david palmer says
is it pretty women that secretly run the
world and ugly are mad about it
yeah i've heard that all wars about
women fought over women
nah spices or religion food
yeah food wars who started that rome
they're like hey
we love food isn't it isn't it like more
people have died over food tasting good
than anything else
yeah have you heard the joke huh have
you heard the joke how funny it is that
british people waged so many wars and
colonized so many places for spices and
now they literally
don't put any on that yeah
you want to hear a joke that i was told
when i went to norway oh boy yeah
is this allowed on youtube i was told
this by some norwegians and they're very
they're very well cultured they said uh
how come there are no pretty women in in
great britain
how come because we stole them all that
i was told that by some like i think
the viking raids i don't think it's a
joke i think it was being serious
he's like i was just teaching you you
know norwegian history terrifying no it
is true though
they that's what that's well that's all
the beautiful russian women are here
because they're like mail order get me
out yep yep
russia it's also kind of cool
very cool but then it kind of sucks
and then it's cool again ray coren says
ian your
your lack of knowledge of christianity
is astounding to be fair i think
everyone here has a lack of knowledge of
christianity sheamus is probably one of
the most
well versed please watch the series the
chosen you can download the app and
watch for free
largest crowdfunded show in history it
is true i don't have much theology jack
jack murphy's been reading the bible
oh yeah i saw that yeah you know jack
jack murphy yes
he's been reading the bible i just got a
hand-painted bible from my sister-in-law
it was used and it's beautiful and it's
sitting there and i'm like
well i suppose i should do this because
i started asking i'm like is there any
verses in the bible about being a better
wife or this or that
yeah and then she like gives me this
book and i'm like
okay god i guess i gotta read your books
31 the bible talks ian i would recommend
you read
the 31st proverb because it lays out the
ideal woman and she is not a passive
stay-at-home woman
she works she has her own business she
runs her family she knows what's up
and the bible they put her price
quote-unquote far above rubies and i'm
like that's really powerful that's
really meaningful
interesting matt bowler says
might have to hire tim as a matchmaker
because he keeps having beautiful common
sense no-nonsense women on who would
make great mates
oh honey i am so taken
we don't stay on the market sane women
the insane women keep you know
functioning through
breakup break up breakup drew richmond
says tim around a hundred thousand
chinese men
built trenches in france for the triple
anton in world war one
some stayed after and married locals
there was also a theory that the chinese
workers spread the spanish flew to
kansas when they traveled through canada
interesting i didn't know that
hmm wolfstar says tim now supports
cancel culture
in regards to the olympic athletes not
facing the flag for the anthem
i've never seen anyone flip on a stance
so fast
um what what what's what's what's the
full
context of me supporting cancel culture
for saying
no disrespect if you don't want to be
there why don't you leave so someone
else can be there
thanks for giving him your money for
your stupid opinion
thanks adrian sorry
yeah but i actually think i have a
fairly uh a fairly nuanced take on
cancel culture anyway
like we've had this conversation tucker
carlson was asked by somebody
what would you allow someone on the show
if they used a racial slur and he said i
wouldn't like exactly
there are limits and so i can't remember
who we were talking about this uh we're
we're talking to about this
that conservatives have a
misunderstanding of free speech and
making
are making a mistake by defaulting to we
should allow all free speech yeah we
have a list of things that we talk about
with every guest
before we do the show this show that you
can't say don't do
don't do this don't talk about this
don't talk about that yeah but that's
like that's not your fault no
censor yourself so no one else has to
that's us saying don't swear
and like youtube has two very specific
things they'll ban us for if you say
yeah it's important don't bang the table
and we even after the swearing thing
where like if you swear
you know it's kind of funny but it's not
like we're saying we don't you can't you
can't talk about your opinions on
you know you can't talk about the
opinions that youtube doesn't want you
to talk about
which are the things i want to talk
about which is everything i want to talk
about and believe in
completely there are a handful of things
absolutely but that's why we had to set
up the website
because it's uh the the risk is do we
just shut the show down
oh i i signed up yeah that's
that is reality though it's the future
of internet broadcast
direct to tv direct to your your uh
unfortunately
but there's uh like we had when we had
bannon on
the first thing i asked him was the one
thing that you do i watched it it was so
good i can't repeat what he said though
i'm not gonna say a word but every
single one
said i love you know i used to hate him
because of my democratic
south side chicago programming i knew
nothing about him
and i watched him on your show and i was
like hey that's that guy that i used to
be programmed to like i'm like i love
everything he has to say that's a normal
guy
he says he's far right but i'm like
what's far right about him everyone's
far
right that's not crazy purple-haired
screaming and
ripping out their own flesh i i feel
like
everyone is far right anymore liberals
are fart bill maher
everyone's far right do you see on the
show when he was like talking about the
election and i was like i will save it
and he goes i'm not going to say the
magic words
like he's not a young man oh yeah
i noticed with a lot of the comments for
the steve bannon stuff was
i didn't know anything about this guy
except for what i heard through the
mainstream news he's
nothing like what they said he was like
oh they're all they're liars
they demonized him yeah that's crazy
it's really crazy how he's like we gotta
help the working-class people and tax
the rich yeah
i hate it's like yourself and i'm like
oh my god and they
brainwashed poor people to hate this man
i it's just really weird william j s
says tim cats show you deserve all the
success with your hard work and
dedication oh and
did uncle eddie luke run away again no
luke we puke
luke did you uh luke did a a great
little presentation at porkfest oh i
haven't seen it
uh it was great he's got a flamethrower
and he says something like freedom
like this flamethrower can be dangerous
and then i think he said something like
but it's all a lot of fun or whatever
and then he
fires the flamethrower and no but it was
a good point freedom is dangerous
like we need responsibility you know you
you've got a lot of people who are like
i don't trust you with your freedom so
we should control everything you do
you have the other people who are like
yeah well you know
i trust myself to keep myself safe so
you do your thing and i'll keep myself
i'll worry about myself i thought do you
i don't know if you saw the friday show
with you you and me
was is that her name i i was on the show
but i watched some of it and she was
saying that freedom is painful
for someone that has never experienced
because you have to think for yourself
and it's
dangerous and scary that you do it wrong
when i was in moscow the moscow times
had a poll
about freedom and it said his freedom
good or bad and it said 98
of the people polled said that freedom
was a bad
thing they also had an image of jessica
simpson in the back as an
escort apparently in moscow you could
hire jessica simpson
as an escort i took a picture and then
tmz stole it and didn't even give me
credit and did an article with my
picture
like in 2008 it was like jerks jerks
yeah luke dab says adrian just
referenced return to oz the dark crystal
the neverending story and full out
quoted bilbo baggins
did we just become best friends yes
i'm old and i'm a nerd old nerd yeah
it's true story i met my husband on
twitch
playing um not world of warcraft the
card game that's like world hearthstone
yep that's how i met my husband were you
playing against each other no
i i'd streamed out of nowhere and i
played it and he came in i'm like
duck sauce isn't that that big wow
streamer i was like i play well and i'm
a guild master and he's like an i'm a
guild master and he was horde
and i was not and then i faction and
server changed
and said there can be only one yeah who
challenged him for the title of
guildmaster and defeated him
no he was the guild master because of
the patriarchy
which which expansion was it uh oh my
god
what did i what what the night fallen
what were the elves that were like uh
zombie things i totally forget what
expansion that was we
lost interest completely after work not
the draenor right
well we met in 2015 no russell lich king
was the best expansion
of all space time but i don't even
remember what were we on pandaria or
whatever the death note
oh pandaria that was the one i
introduced that i was hosting
blizzcon for directv and they showed the
pandas
and then they came to me on live tv and
i was with like swifty the wow player
and i had them in my microphone they're
like what do you think and i was like
wrath was awesome wrath was the fly they
let you fly
oh my god everything about arthas was
good everything about her
it's just a sad story what class
pandaria was like
that's when i was like i'm not
interested in ever playing this and then
i played again in legion then i played
it and then i played uh
that was that was basically i played
legion yeah we played a legion and then
what class and race i was draenei death
knight
and then before that i was a night elf
warrior and then with my husband of
course i have to be pretty so it was a
blood elf
i hate being an orc i don't want to be
an ugly
thing i want to be hot with hooves
isn't it isn't it like amazingly racist
they made kung fu pandas and jamaican
trolls
they even talk with that accent i know
it's like what
that's so i didn't even think of it that
way i know who cares you would
go to escape and not care i hate pc the
kung fu panda thing i
laughed like when i saw that came out i
was like to me i was like what the heck
is this
it was so
is that what this is from so is kung fu
it's just very like
culturally appropriate did it happen
like right after kung fu panda came out
yeah uh uh
wasn't it i had a while after i just
remember it was awful
i blew through it i got the expansion
later after it was already onto the next
expansion so i just flew through it
10 levels an hour but it was terrible i
just cancelled my
subscription and i haven't played now in
years every time something new comes out
i'll like
puddle around for a second and i'm like
this sucks i still have one um because i
played
what's the what's the new expansion
called uh
was it the one that's what i'm saying
was it the zombie elves
those cool night elves that are like
zombies and they need
drugs they need meth what's the i don't
even remember the latest man i played
the latest one where they go to the
other side that's how much burning
crusade no
burning legion no this is like cataclysm
all that stuff this is why
it sucked so bad we can't even remember
what we committed time to to say this
sucks
yeah i made a demon hunter and then i
played like one level and quit yeah i
had a demon hunter too i don't even
remember
when classic came out i played again for
sure yeah classic
i didn't play my husband was like i
spent my entire life playing
classic to get to this point why do i
want to relive that yeah it started to
feel like that
yeah all right let's see we'll do it
we'll do a couple more and then uh
sorry for the warcraft i could do a
whole warcraft show man
oh yeah arthas but
the the the trailer for wrath was so
amazing
i will still watch it my husband does
voiceovers and he can do that
perfect that dude he's like my son oh my
god do it again
it's so well done blizzard makes amazing
short films like the last bastion do you
see that one
no overwatch man that one was so we got
into overwatch my husband played it all
the time
always late to dinner what i didn't like
is that the reticule doesn't move when
you run it's just perfectly still in the
middle of the screen so there's no like
gunplay challenge
whereas like borderlands your guns
bouncing around you got to like hold
your breath
there's always that hunter guy because
he was a hunter and wow and he's a
hunter in real life
yeah he always played that dude genji's
brother
yeah all right we'll just do we got we
got one more here uh jerome graves says
tell duck to stream again
plox i miss his arena matches yeah he's
not gonna do it
my husband left twitch and i left
hollywood and
it's a good thing and now you're
mountain recluses yeah
we hate everyone we're not gonna give
you entertainment
well my friends we are gonna give you
entertainment so
go to timcast.com become a member
because we're gonna have
a bonus segment coming up and you can
follow the show
at tim cast irl on facebook and
instagram we want to leverage these
networks get everybody to the website
make sure you smash the like button
subscribe to this channel and follow me
personally at tim cast
we do the show monday friday live at 8
00 pm also got the vlog from cast castle
that's happening every
week and we just hired or just about to
hire three people we've like
confirmed details with everybody so now
it's just paperwork and then
daily vlogs every day do you wanna
adrian shout anything out social media
at adrian curry everywhere except for
twitter
um yeah that that's pretty much it
adriennecare.com whatever
i'm not really that active and it's fine
if you don't check me out
because i get it but they'll see you in
the chat yeah
now i don't know if i'm gonna troll it
as much as i used to now
there's no fun when you guys see my face
glad you're here uh you guys follow me
in crossland.net and at ian crossland on
social media
thanks a lot this has been an incredibly
fun conversation with adrienne
i've really enjoyed this i've enjoyed
being around another amazonian woman
i have to say that it means a great deal
to me to feel like feminine it's a big
deal right you want to feel feminine you
want to feel pretty and petite
those things unless you're around giants
you guys can follow me at sour patch
lids on twitter as i attempt to gain
more followers than sour patch kids
how's that coming by the way uh so far
so good we're getting closer
but sour patch kids is also getting more
flowers too
you have to no one follows you unless
you show skin
oh yeah everyone's like what's with your
followers i'm like i put it all away
sorry yeah yeah still there it's just
not for you
that's right we will see all of you over
at timcast.com thanks for hanging out
bye guys
you